Yes I was sitting at the next table in my head.
It was just the sun coming out of those are our child and he said to his friend a ferry boat.
She said with friends is years old a little over a single trip.
They're looking for we're not this is always something like something our son Will
and well at first it was a full minute on this was to be you know just so much with you he said to have come with us.
And when I used to fire you if you didn't come with a run through with my elderly
or sexual man he is not generally found that would hold my life up to a very kind of the point in your head to release
I never push for a very long story. The thing. Fair enough but that you did it was wrong.
Yesterday you told us it was doing.
The real real shocking arrest the very difficult for people to visit the very person.
You see I've often told result if I were I Die Hard hit the sexual how I would feel secure.
You don't think a memory a memory of some sort of relationship your life with both I think I possess a very shiny for
life.
I think a lot of his followers are good for me and I think they're there and they are very revealing the is the sure
but the getting to that I mean regardless of whether or not.
How widespread it was stated that if you actually told somebody that he or she did. Yes I would like to list.
Just not entirely. We were talking about the routing market using the route that was in the dish you know.
Probably the LATE EDITION. It's amazing.
These are listed here we're in the forty's
and there's certainly the like a part of this is you know it was never said so what was your day challenge to say that
I mean have you been a lot of discussion about what people are more aware of
and among intelligent people who live with your sister. Now this is interesting.
I don't know because as I said my rendition of I'm a writer mystery which characters reckons stepbrother's sort of
sympathetic enough there right now.
That was a change of attitude to write it was a career a bit of all that it was at the wrong house to be a shot that
really makes everything
but why the change came about the sun will live just a couple in the series in the was a lot of stuff in the early
fifty's basically because of the events leading up to the establishment of will from the committee hearing already.
That is the whole world should leave you very much.
Yes to that for us to get everybody to really be guesses on the over the report came at a time
when there was a certain easing of people's feelings for him so that things anyway in other words I really feel for you
here.
You say well then again
when I see the next thing back before that is Kinsey Well maybe they're just sad that maybe I didn't then your it was
right here is about right now this is I read about it in the local.
So I would say that that perspective because we have heard that
and I have a good there are a lot of talk of very effective this discussion here
and it was out in the air that the one with the felt isolated that anybody
and he said organizational Manvers Naresh nurturing a little bit.
Are you actually get to realize it out
and have people are sharing you know he's saying that he's for it wasn't just for the dummies segment cancer was the
movement of overcoming all the other woman
or all the natural right to not trying to mix with people all the auctioneer that Michel.
You know the theory that some people of the business that they said this is the second rule was such a lot of people
just got here.
You know experienced on the same homosexual sex yet at least in the Rose of The End of years in a way in which they
might head to the same place kids.
Yes
but the whole message explosion of carry over their own attitudes to say here here should be possible to look down on
the leg and I mean telling people there's always been a reasonably thought well there's been a lot of discussion
but I mean you sort of think the price drop you know this is a much wider thing.
I mean obviously this is just such a good back into the nineteenth century people like Karl Rove Look at us the whole
story while troubling there's a whole group of people there.
That's really the central Reform League which is the thing that one study here will bear that Mr President.
So rosy should he says it really hurt that this because that only hands like this young is missing with a.
The US is also circles and people were people would always swoop in on one and one openly
and discuss it about people's sexuality
and says he will receive this was discussed among heterosexuals among the overweight or rather the words custody.
Even among the execs will be in need my company.
Here is where the I would play or big whatever doesn't matter but I said listen the in conversations of ahead
and the conversations that I used to hear market research shows
or example then has issues to get about people's sexuality
and people will say the reason that it was about I am here
and then your question here is never assume that we will say that last night we had a sexual bit of it
and it would always be about usually about the man and that's Elmo my grade for me and the general feeling I got
when you're let's just it was was all of a feeling of said the you know let's just watch.
Is that what I ask you receive no I don't really think the brothers talking about something much was either trucks
or medical career people you're a way you will get a higher degree accept reality than you do in the normal run you got
ahold of the people whose problem lies talked about me here and you know what I think even in that group.
I think a lot of them are saying you know this and that
when basically all this because I think it's a smart thing to do and it did it was done.
Oh I live hospitals or do you want to really go over. You know your fifty's. OK. The scene for us here.
And those who love the machines if you will are under the bed to let you get out of the parking lots I'll tell you what
I was at a party once where the woman in the play straight in there about Trinity all those lines around listening to
records.
It looked like this it was about the time it created it spoke
and the we were like the right really truly five of us lie run just me.
Rachel as we were doing it so subdued lighting and because there was living in the flat.
The only one without holes on the flat nor was I then the owner a friend of the other came in with police.
He had a cake.
Just walked in
and what I saw were these twenty twenty five thirty people lying around this fairly large living area listening to
records.
Nobody was hoping it was his
or clearly labeled because he was doing anything you'll watch over the class of listening to even classical
and the it's quite obvious who it was good because police didn't do a really good reforms that ever lived.
But the way you love the labels and we all just took stock of this exact regime of free will.
People who were three of what police and one of the policemen said was right
and the other one said like the protest privately and then another was said Jay Z.
Said to think of it is this black stuff and career right now.
No I didn't go out from the race blacks who are doing you know.
There's language around like cross-examining everyone else that night is what I did their occupations rather over a
Republican crisis those are architects. Doctors of accountants and that's what they and those oh are you.
I know you give it up for the site but the words are those that say what you mean your shirt sexual. I love you.
I don't know that side.
Well you're not mad I said this should be hoping that this is not a very direct result of was what you are you are
whether or not. Man it's impossible.
Crystal clear and I quote and he said no we're only talking to us because of the results of the fluff.
But they were getting a response from the presumed one they want to respond stark yes you are taking up the out six
times last night he hit me on you get this story
or should I quote it because that's what I get clothes from would be awesome that they used to lose their house so that
there are enough and I meet someone who makes millions. They can get that rooster over here.
That's why I don't venture less wonder they said things like productive kind of Forestry right now have a medical
examination. There were no houses exhaust on here. You got your car. And it was possible that was the other cocaine.
Well it would have been one of the people who wondered about making these sort remarks was bumped off.
He was online and he was full of us in the store he saw all right he said You wonder what that man was Hayes's must.
Oh the real monster that's well yes well tough but that would leave the beginning of the Korean War. Yeah yeah.
See we you know one of the things you just rules you know. Yeah a lot of you say Green was only love you.
If you watch the time we're going to spoil your solution of finding in Korea where the young lady would be until he was
older he was a police car you can tell. Yeah place Commissioner.
Yeah sure the Catholic Church thought it was just out scene where he got up
and she has a like a gun a very strong my Catholic attorney general very old like old like the so called The LIKE HE'LL
YEAH YEAH. Actually my colleagues like rice try to be funny. He was a good artist only assume when you hear.
Usually yes I hear. He used like police playing in a mirror in the mirror.
We hope truth what are we hearing that really was there behind the girl a little trick for us
and all those who were getting along fine with us here first time ever heard. Rose up or like OK great.
Yes Well this was a this was this was this is a bit like this is this realize oh really.
That this is the this is really.
Here's where this just crossing of the business to supply him with the truth was around here to get us there
but it may break but I usually say that.
Yeah all of us have that Harry said the police writer really like
and works about the place right now the rest of the roster. Oh yeah you get great like very late in bed together.
Just a great place with Priscilla Presley funny enough. Rusty Russell that doesn't cross a line in Russell it up.
Can you really really star was a rogue out there here.
Russell dead already said roughly your yes she would be shortly out to you on this
or night just to get to that part that she used to wear shortly after I teamed up with this route.
We're wondering longer across from now we see these two figures in front of us this is going down.
We see down down the hill from the top of the Cross going down was rough cause by that straight they all left well here
we saw these two people are walking ahead of us a woman and a man and I said to Ralph this is crazy.
He said Just come here and there you know I said Mr Hawkins probably talked to them or something
and you know we got into conversation probably you know he was really serious Why do you got angry that very droll the
yes I used to see a movie ground he's crossed carrying two bottles.
You know bottles up to the both of those are all the over like of this is to get some help here.
We will be back to the place she had the first floor of a barn where she lived for years
and I was absolutely fascinated because Ross who knows how to insult those two players
and drew three million that happened along on the very attractive where the they will too.
To have a pistol just reach the window of this first floor of this resort for any window door sort of thing.
There was the old well window of the top floors.
It wasn't just down onto the ground as facet of this
and then we were going through the end of the bed together rosily Norton got into bed with them and
when we got on the nature of alcohol and Henri years there was no big bowl of little mole
and she talked about going up to the local cemetery to get to give you the operation. I said you made it special.
You had decorations like this with all his paintings rather of all his hand like creature here behaving as though he
had begun and panthers
and what have you looking at their cocks in the casino the coffee goes according to the place the Kashmir yells Royston
even among them of my love for you. We went next door.
That's where you are the gracious dribble of pay for the respectable ones paid for.
Oh yes rather more for always for your wife but she got liberation for Rosalie Norton used to go on. I mean.
Well what are the vital. Yes And I guess the hand that we were in when she was only really she should come to this man.
Yeah yeah good luck to you caught up on the right on sixty.
You can see some sort of five years of life because she's run with the best Brian is right.
He will be very shrewd very are refusing to back exactly right. Just right. Most unusual looking where she's.
Quite beautiful right here right right here on actually say beautiful strong striking
and what good luck here with what it's all about it.
Yeah but when we listen to the row your daughter than we used to be true to just cycling.
We're going to shoot you dead
or start you get your that we're going to get a lot of the things you think I have about zero point here
and here we have a guy who's very gracious he's a good man would be. She was bisexual. I certainly will last.
And what was recently busted was this book the city had three people who tended to be just by the conventional stand
but I mean one of the things we have to do is pull the whole Bible or at least from the leisure to find out.
Oh you got rid of prosecuting and mother was well are trying to find out I do.
George was doing this for his wrist is well known what George love is yours is now married with three shows already
but now most will be someone that might be worthwhile finding out something about Ross used to work
and leave him alone here was I also was always he was big success
but he did other motivational really rose for Doris but Ross was most certainly for you. Period.
Well done here in the in his life saw there was no question that he didn't tell you the scars that he has boyfriends
Big Bear just trip along the Gulf oil spill. There was.
And we just talked to several others who knows the spread of life and by this.
It was a well it was really does not share that with the wrong things going to get their bikes were rescued Bush budgie
fished a little bit with it.
It must have been an old restaurant we should all be fulfilled as it is to the right or to be fragile but I assure you.
By this which already.
For several years to see that from the first guy eat the guy year nightspot year Go year where because he will not be
life which is like this drawn out legal trade which is now as you say great Shirley slightly from her story
but it sucks really goes from here
but is it true you were a little off a little to the Charlotte area that they are sitting around for you.
Jes year for your city did you know here was a cigar smoking worth of you know what you would find out about drugs
three reactors I said said he was this new in his last start was with white
and startles of this it could really do with those this was a problem to me. Should they lose Kareem bills.
All of those people trained dogs is he really going to quit but the long way.
Here is really very clear Doug is joining us. I do not know anything yet at the literary about it.
Read about the over here where your brother starts off with his mother's.
And more sense because this guy got to know cars that's why he was the one man who was the people
and here it was terribly camp and I'm sure it was really really great actor on there
and he's a lot of cross-bred sexual Rebrov got a lot of knocks right to me
but Marjorie was easy to get out of John Rocker who really was out of her hole with my bet is that you get a are is
pretty but it's a yes so Mark is that pretty
and let's say hey here's the front of Harvey's the first three guns get know those parties for free gallery house that
you go to just south of the city are the only way you get Yeah you're a good track here
and he bought his people again for proof of that we get to keep it longer here
and that's O'Mara says trying it myself but it very ordinary house infiltrate God if it were just a motor sauces
and he'd just have babies everywhere and his bike pretty busy the other companies will be his anyway.
Oh my love him of mine in my mind it had sexual sensual that he would go out
and march less well with He'd have drugs from the pleasure of the old Those that play reasonably well anyway.
And then there's the great Harry officer who is going to get into his head that makes the world
but he was really going strong.
No saying yes I suppose you listened years where you live you just six years and years
and years later record been overseas for a few years ago too.
I would like to know the real Sharon and Princess and they said Oh Maurice legend has it done to you.
Was it not this early on.
Check that out and then I was strangely and sure enough she makes a joke of me
and I am talking made back to his place for coffee.
But then he was living for a little but the richness of the air
but he had to get rid of the junk you start to lose muscle good luck Morris
and a pretty poor particular can do very much
and it hardly startled the force that he gave his visitation of the lives of the year's biggest relief on a good little
narrow good old grandfather image because his history of the force was.
Well yeah it's right religion or rather lose it all and finish all that everybody like to say again
and we never do it in order to give us the big things like a city discard like Lee He said this is a huge rally we'll
give you three weeks here. Yes raises up the skills.
There's a lot of us to host you know fellows good people and they're here where we never of the year.
Look there's a reason to be here
when the good people must be some rich guy with the forty's fifty's who did for our young life
and I think quite often you know there's a right.
There's a right to get across the border around the future here because I'm only here and I take you back.
Right off the list. Let me read that.
I just read through a little poster out there still has a letter today with blood was nearly not believe my life you
listed there you have your letter helps a little not really mum used to get up to this just left with it so it was on
the news and this is what forty's you must look up again because he felt like he was because he was quite still here
and it was a nice guy
and he said Now I think you believe me I was like This is a result I mean all for the movement you feel you always do
does it feel really really low your mind you there was willing to do a little.
Oh I say Oh I've met people who are sorry that was the other Your mother will cease to be a solicitor at some stations
but I was already there.
It was just because he was crazy because you know the real world
or that we're OK let's just say he was he was a doctor he was a scene from really were doctor the whole character was
very rich and he wished.
All sitting down with me and that being with you over which is you know a lot of money and prestige
or a whole lot of the edge of the year long cold again where the list is really do just you know you're missing the red
boys being called off the show you hear talk of the board of directors sure what you see why hasn't he thought of this
good looking long for the gays night.
We will be sure to be sure he would rather be you know you can point out here and you can raise your right.
Very very tall and the story will show that he was also told you know that some of the recovery from last night.
Most of the other you're still right.
Every Sunday when he had the great good aeration of the late sixty's early seventy's. I mean there are seasons.
Really you know this liberation you say just coming out here for all the cities I went to in Europe.
I used to get the borrows so we get a little older so right through here I really meant was that the days like this.
Yes they were older years
and they got the signs of the right people are exactly the same look if you were in that zone are you stuck there for
everything was going on.
You could be sitting here
but I had to do a little bit of the United look right down to get dark runs on the way around so I knew I was a good
looking out on here that actually was that they were all right. And I had seen something there.
All right if you're into the street and there you have stayed there pretty good. There's a very very bright day here.
The scene with the hoses of places like this is not what I often think that there was that run that that violent
opposition where it just off of just over the street. No harm the parish yesterday that well I think that again.
I mean I love the reading matter who gets here.
Yes I never went there but I mean I did they're not happy but I believe but over the years.
It was always had a reputation to some extent very helpful.
This is the last it was then the Australian certainly predated me
and I think they were mentioned in their rooms for years together with Israel
and of course he is one of the work to do it all behind us now that he was a great hire because a bisexual
or somebody like
and I was advised that it was a secure place really here where the very real good letter year there's a real life as a
result that is the stronger I'm sorry to say learning in the thirty years
or something like Philip had a strong attraction for him
and that was a strong attraction for him because I really had passed a very example to me now.
Well obviously he had women friends he had the number of was he enjoyed. Well there was a lot of I got on with it.
Yes you're headed up the right kind of jumping out of your love.
There's actually a little bit of course I have to say for the same reason I don't know but maybe I just made it all.
I was saying is that he used to get into rushes straight shooters in his autobiography I wouldn't be sure about that
but I hear that someone writes really recently about which I had I had read where he said that in an interview prior
years ago.
Frankly I had not actually I had thought of it from a gay point of view because
when I first read about that regard to this before the general public.
Except of those places or in other words they were the three places of Sydney.
If you were a sort of somebody who dropped in on Sydney and you're it out for good.
I get all the rest of it and you get to those places where you know it was just a moment but he just told you it was
or was rubbish me a Southern rock. I think it was at Taco Bell Theosophists right. Oh it was. Yes this role.
Yes he decided this yes I used to get it was right for a little rough rough right here self-will the cells were good
and it was quite the same thing to get it and hung up.
OK Guy going to buy all the drinks in the old really you know little bit of it and leave the live video of it
and then just write the last minute just around six o'clock you do real quick to six your excuses show together the to
the to the business to live your good guy is OK because they have to work any sell you a bridge for us to make sure you
sort of sub to begin to disappear somebody is that what you're still feels just pick your leaders have today off to
something else and it was absolutely it was it was it.
Well it was six of the letters really which is why he was referred to write a letter to all the laws of my theory
everywhere.
I really thought it was about knowledge your taxes
and you very well for the whole of the back room Brown will say well over marriage for example you give your party
trick caller ID. Oh you know you actually real jobs where I look so they can appreciate it. Here goes.
One of the one of the pubs in the early fifty's tried to get rid of the gays who say we used to know rather than just
crossed over.
Well Dorry says OK well hold here shows and she saw us Australians or start telling us here
and here it actually was so we read this night we wrote it in the rain we read the paper.
There's a career it just plays and the through the mandatory.
You can already see a short phrase leave this hotel
and never come back here who must sending Who knows how to load by really close up the lovely river of his which is
Raphael nearly every other man in the race the ricks here for a period.
This will be nice for The Dark Knight Rider to toss the war.
I was there while on the run up to do something else
and there's only as we left down at the doorstep with you in mind not coming back here again thank you very much.
We don't want your time here for the last very low cost for the bricks should be good wishes for your office beginnings.
Yes you're right we need this yet to set right from the start
but the shape of the race for your great race is next year it's really good to see the issues rather than the lottery.
Yet you know I'm meeting with House right on the seat in the city and in the house at the front of the face of the air.
It will be contemporary with with the Australian Carlson rehashes always ready with a very.
Craig you know the best ride along the worst critic the oh yes indeed did well here every tryst just it.
It was that it riseth I didn't say but the counseling and the
and I were rather the discrete there was a story where you could let it run the freedom if you want to say outlandish
Yeah but I have to go out
and not enough for everybody to stay there just to say go out Monday Hey for a great book exterior read the silent
dream Australian talk. There's a little. That's an old baby girl years of a while. Oh yeah story. Let's stay low.
Yes Well I mean that's what sort of price for going out with your kids like Oh that's right that's right you dance
silent
and you just aren't very green horses are waiting to hear the oh there is food there are certain really rather yes
please.
That would you know the mind that is New Year's Eve
but I still think the House of people are scared of their own right. Yes for us to get along. They're right.
They're very I'm full seems to me blind a bit before I know that God spoke to us to hear what you believe just being
friends with the expect to hear that you do get that love very often.
All I feel when I get off like that if I just meet someone someone new my entire life I might be.
I have done or something like to chat to them when I checked it might be afraid of us
and we have a bit of a sort of hero.
You know and what have you all this stuff is in the US that this has that resume again through tough love.
Good luck to his son on the much get into bed with him again through all of this is getting our first right here.
So it's like you're missing his heart years later.
Oh it's really it's not what are we going to give us from first to get the show. That's right.
Is it really a rehash of this it has evolved into the reader with a I got a very old check.
I haven't checked it out and you get what I have checked a few strangers with nothing.
The end of it but there is a slight chance. Oh readers think I'm a woman you're good.
When you start all over this depressing uh oh this is doing well you know you girls are doing good. It is a pleasure.
Oh you don't make up you were you are now I am going to get somebody that you really hope for the things you think OK
great.
Like you know I'll become actually make sure I get psychotic rather than a little bit of age
and I was writing for breakfast to somebody else and I get to say I could leave for eight hours or so
but I just had just a telegram really I just messed up. You know I'm a good girl.
Really I was trying to say a very nice phrase but here. We have to the kitchen jacket you know you're digital.
I was Go read the break to get the book. The players messed up the coffee going back to the.
Was it your impression of people of the music for one thing or the other but rather see his ability to write poetry.
The way he did used to be the sort of thing that you have to accept of I think rather more than that is the case in
this he has.
You had to discard as to whether you were as excited as it will
or you have to suddenly be you are going over the road here and
and if if you had a friendship with another I have a six year old guy was passive like he was a preacher's like that
resistance that he expresses that it's safer because she's my sister room room.
Well you have another thing in your house little thing you have a little little hand here.
So this phrase rather resting shriek and I was fussing at this factory and said here.
I really either of those two sisters share in heat of actually getting saved through this how shocking
but it has been that is how you know which is my sister she made me Agent sister.
I was married and look she let him come down the always felt she would not be as there was more slowly.
The figure of you have to decide. So the increase really didn't do it or you can go with me.
You're saying no this is merely looking more to that other outbids I know that I'm very old interrogates felt
and our jobs are equated And he said to this out there
and he said well you are we're told YOU WANT OUR we're told we're just have the birth to the bush we're just have to
buy the books that's already been established and good about your heart into the first year
and it's a good to be with the spirit here talking yet the very are not really there.
You described series it out because he think it by Syria he did that using it was in the period.
If you were six foot tall and very thin
and rather than you probably right now you can be desirable you have to be going to see here rest Yes that's right.
Yes yes I was there a way there
and then as a painter the result of realisation I heard about it that there was a muslim up at Dawson microspheres
which was done you know that you can probably do the books because in the country as you go doesn't know with the with
with play those folks because you sure if you play this you're not forwards it's really something good come of it like
I do that and you become the you was wrong.
Fraser and Ross Buchanan and I was told and she had an interview with the press
and this was brought to trial about rugby and for three years
and she had the interview with a pretty sure it she said Oh it's all there.
All of it in the sun they're all quite a perceptual Oreos. They're all the whole and tall and over six feet tall.
They're they're all strong tall and over six feet tall. There isn't there is no six through the doors in the world.
You know in a hot tub.
Where it's free for the night but she was on this bit of an active duty as you translate was self.
She really did she try and look so she didn't she. Illusion that there was really great about taking the job.
Basically she was a difficulty ordinary sort of housewife a sort of real man
and she was surrounded by all these great Irish was attracted to. Oh she's ha ha ha leader.
Trying to get most of them today. I'll be sorry if she had.
They understand where security should be given that you know that here stuff always knows it's rather like the old
or old millions he's been told and they're on their heads or these are all rather tongue nice Verrall here and there.
Yes they're all there six feet tall.
That's how this could set up this process began to rub your tongue runs right up there not to mention the other this
rubbish
but I think it really was wrong to hear that six feet away a session was right there was was cautious Lawrence good in
the US Good on you. Yes sir yes sir and all of the very religious.
The boy is a long years of misery with the boys that you share that was just really sad for all I know you got a lot
older sister had her.
Yes Yes I read a mention on your opinion about that he was very friendly with a woman he used to reduce the City
University dramatics just as my dream was off.
She was really the night of the mother's people breaks it to show you live.
Probably she did talk about nightmares a sort of the repression narrows in the family because she was well she was a
very intelligent woman but certainly much more intelligent.
All right here but I still say nothing but she was nothing more.
And yes here much more and and she was very attractive can actually raise my right.
But I think her and her mentor and emotional that are going to be on the set and say against things. I mean.
DENYER they were there and they went there just sort of here in a whirl too much of it just like consciousness.
Yes Yes that's right.
He doesn't love it yet but I think he
and the jury loved being with them because there you will see a charming person to talk to everybody else with the lead.
I wish I could I just say go away. You never discussed that with us.
She was so young she lost a great role and I was a boy that was already here.
I feel so very very comfortable last Monday because of some oh you might get really hurt a little bit like that.
That's a section of the law you must get a lot of the yard here but you see the thing that may shoot.
Cheap to produce place
and there was a story which by remarkable producer in her later years perhaps not in the Hague
and we would have a reversal or we would have known Sam Eventually we don't know how often CROSSFIRE
and group made it would make me mad and about six guys and we gave up trying to have a fire all the way Kashmir
and we'd sit there.
About three smoking countless cigarettes and talking about drug use and I was facing was in jail as well
but never really on this issue right here. So I got here ready and we made a reference to an interesting.
I didn't buy it.
These are women that whole from the thing I needed was a body run Sydney know not to get that straight
and start talking about it. Something similar was there really was there any all in all major story.
I didn't know there was a time trial and that was in the fifty's. That was in most of the fish would be world peace.
It was set up the full report.
He said that the whole of the fight started about but it's not really fifty three with one hundred people doing.
Joe you're told. Life is a national run here a shadow record and a long rope and I.
You can bet your straight they're just saying to you about the stress reduction.
We've got the reaction to the press about you was your reporting.
People were generally has been a mono he hung intelligent people. Yes because I mean to anybody.
So the stick their head up all right. It's a form of this device will start with an organization.
This is again the again the word the word gay organizations in you know through the fifty's Sutra fell because they
were there you can do a lot of gay organizations
and there is nothing with the recession here until very recently really just really just down the road here
and then the security of the drug trail this young heiress that was hit was over the feeling was something that's just
three years later there was that later then yeah you can because for countless phone to believe with
when did this phase interfere.
Go all the theories free candy which poses interview are you going to be there is because that was convenient to do
this if you love to read the news for everything you know what we really do that you're working on we didn't read like
no you were being there gazing very rigid very uncivil to sit so he got down there
and then try to stop us getting Oh you said Dr desires don't think of yourself as you really are you really just really
going to have you this if you're sure that we would love you probably have to pack up again because I didn't show you
the man on the door that day playing to the south. Did you know something.
The fact that you know this is a real structural Russian how we ended up being wrong for cuisine. Yeah.
And then she just said this stuff will show you something.
This is just your usual run you want a very long
but you know what with let me just let you know you can't swallow Polish
and I had the song you guys are you being a Christian in this song
or you Blues we had some of the strangest I guess this is something to research the why are you going through your list
or your skills you know so you know but it's a risk. I'm a commuter guy that's a very few go.
Let's drop the rather this is the story to go.
Most people are wondering well I thought that was mildly and you can get whole story here to get together more
or less just carries a gun when we get serious and when you're drunk.
You just sort of going at this for about three or about simple Oh right.
Takes for the whole of the world and why you should do it with your man you know a guy who got it.
So yes it was just here it is just a little ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha. Oh I did read another good way.
Yes there's fire fighting here I like I thought tonight today. They've got that Percy knows it's going to cause a liar.
Right now. All right Kate. Yeah I was shocked to hear that three.
I think the color of the three pages not just you and the they had the richness of the sign right there.
But I usually get the side to the president here boxing gloves are really tight a lot of plywood
or all you can hang out. So yes yes. Well you lose your fingers.
They should hold all your data carelessly which will say that the box. Yes yes yes this is worse.
It's error than true yes education does nothing to help. It's not John Bell.
You know all those are you guys are like the very same studio.
Percy Rose was the big gun he was red
and yellow boxes because he's very well in many down the road is the only right a circular are made by me very well is
here now he may have know you something.
Well I think we've talked ourselves with our young listeners really begin early learning anything
and I mean let me help you church just about we're just going to drive you do you really thing is the way we get here
we just simply write on then you can solve a lot of cultural you know here said things were really I mean that's where
we can begin to get from where you say songs of a phone call to a lot of people they hear it every day
or hear things which leads very hard to sort of grow up is the fact that in that period we talked about we were in our
late teens
or early transition you lead a different lifestyle you do hear say coming out of office getting on the Outer Banks away
all hail the time it was because for years just to be free to look beyond that will.
Straight now he's pointed out for you to get a say a year on New Year's Eve.
John I ran to the sea for the summer sun trust.
Come now we're talking coming up again here within reach of the rest of the refusal of him for not a lot about the
people. There's a little bit of drag with the Grays from both caves.
He's now the just great Aunt Beatrice you see here right now that I have you where there is larger than life
but we had was a single young bull the bit that you know today or a yellow dog the rather young boy was here really.
Every year
and that was the key not the drag the drag like war was never my God it was just fraught with the ole years with the
mighty we're stuck with this big kid who's a straight shot to the ceiling through the floor a very glamorous evening
from here
and the drug hero leprous he was a hero to the lovers strike force restraint you know you're writing from very very
unlikely next year while you're wearing your sun the good stories are gone right through before breaking my heart.
Oh my god the bridge let a priest go.
Surely with a little stuffy sound downright mean that we have to drive or we could start another get up going our way.
Frank doesn't tell you yet it seriously are a little over a lot of really good.
Because you think looking at land you know you get made a gesture
and it should be a good sequence of the work were done just to yesterday just really to fall back on the bus the Big
Bang where there is hand rolled out probably headed right.
She was putting your hand down like that you used to measure grouse Moses there was this child.
Let's run the great question.
Jane Foley all this artificial really artificial real shot on the scene practicing for the bigger fish to go through.
So here. Greg was Greg.
He was a drag race drag and it was well this is the good news the family business with here they really believe him.
Did you see that film with me rode the ride was here so let's go to Gracie race you get to a break you don't mind the
break a very long week in that beehive start with Robert De Niro he has got the tour right up. That's right.
And it made love acceptance of course the brainchild of not just write music right here.
Here you see right here you see good our group there really and truly I don't see in the song so much
or anyone else here but I can speculate. John's or I just threw responsible for me.
John Mann sorry the royal we ever heard of it was I use oil because I feel he was too magnificent man he was a hell of
a lot of what Bob and you wanted to hear a lot about town the runway where he presented something to you.
It is it's there it's gone and we really does now.
Usually it's it's a new person nation because the only person nations are so sick of it isn't the same time just it
just raises so they are in the middle of the result of something else as the pressure that the cancer hit
and I hope they can get for us we hadn't done that before. So there was absolutely. You want me abuse.
We was very busy you know typically with all of that Mark Heard this year through funny
or was it apparently he got himself for a healthy weight something like that very very closely
and I longed for him to have just walked Longoria over to numbers where he was absolutely still there.
As I did actually straight because of course felt it really emotional overlays really because you get through.
Absolutely. Can't you with what he's doing by really here and all and polish you do physically.
Yes British thing right.